en tunisie la place à de nouvelles
mesures et un protocole sanitaire plus
stricte les gouvernorats sont confinés
les déplacements intra région sont
interdits en cause les chiffres
épidémique qui repartent à la hausse
les précisions à à tunis avec notre
correspondant bastien chebbi cent
dix-huit nouveaux décès en 24 heures la
tunisie traverse la plus sombre période
depuis le début de la pandémie de
coronavirus avec au total quinze mille
deux cent soixante et un décès depuis la
crise près de 2 millions de tunisiens
ont déjà reçu une première dose du
vaccin et près de 600 milles ont reçu
les deux doses sur un total de 12
millions d'habitants que compte le pays
insuffisant pour le ministère de la
santé qui souhaite accélérer cette
campagne vaccinale une propagation
rapide et importante qui a poussé les
autorités à prendre de nouvelles mesures
et un protocole sanitaire strict
couvre-feu à 20 heures fermeture des
mosquées des salles de sport des lieux
culturels report des événements publics
et privés interdiction de circuler entre
les régions ou encore le port du masque
obligatoire sous peine d'une amende de
60 dinars l'équivalent d'une vingtaine
d'euros de nouveaux gouvernorat eux ont
été placés en confinement total
notamment dans le nord-ouest du pays où
le taux d'incidence a dépassé les 400
contaminations pour cent mille habitants
face au manque de moyens matériels
humains ou encore financiers certains
gouvernorats comme celui de manouba ont
décidé d'ouvrir une cagnotte pour
recevoir les dons destinés à soutenir le
secteur de la santé